So, bootstrapping is the act of pulling
yourself up by your bootstraps, really.
It's a form of flying, and in business,
what you do with bootstrapping, or
what it means is, you're going to take
what's immediately available to you.
What's within arm's reach?
What value can you pull out of
the things that are immediately
accessible to you?
It does not mean reaching
out to others or
asking someone to to give you something
that you can then carry forward.
Bootstrapping is about independence,
it's about self value.
It's about creating something that will
allow you to scale your business or
effort down the road starting
essentially from nothing.